you
[Music]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
laureates
ladies and gentlemen that are installed
era at 4% tiara noble Prince Targaryen
literature sizzler a noble yasin order
loose cybernetic them that make them who
know to do your room
it is a great honor to introduce the
Nobel laureate in literature writer
Orhan Pamuk
[Applause]
why to rent why do you write this is the
question I've been asked most often in
my work in my writing career most of the
time they mean this what is the point
why do we give your time to this strange
and impossible activity why do you write
you have to give an excuse an apology
for writing this is how I have felt
every time I have heard this question
but every time I give a different answer
sometimes I say I do not know why I
write but it definitely makes a feel
good I hope you feel the same way when
you read me sometimes I say that I'm
angry and that is why I write most of
the time the urge is to be alone in a
room so that is why I write in my
childhood I wanted to be a painter I
painted everyday I still have that
childish feeling of joy and happiness
whenever I write I write to pursue that
all childish happiness and that is why
for me literature and writing are
inextricably linked with happiness or
the lack of its unhappiness in my
childhood I felt happy I painted a lot
and all the grown-ups were constantly
smiling at me everybody was gentle
polite and tender I wrote all about this
in my autobiographical book Istanbul
after the publication of Istanbul some
people asked me this question aren't you
a bit young to write your autobiography
I kept my silence literature is about
happiness I wanted to say about
preserving your childishness all your
life keeping the child in you alive now
some years later I've received this
great prize this time the same people
began asking another question aren't you
a bit young to get the Nobel Prize
actually the question I've heard most
often since the news of this price reach
me is how does it feel to get the Nobel
Prize I say oh it feels good all the
grown-ups are constantly smiling at me
suddenly everybody is again gentle
polite and tender in fact I almost feel
like a prince I feel like a child then
for a moment I realized why sometimes I
have felt so angry
this prize which brought back to me the
tender smiles of my childhood and the
kindness of the strangers should have
been given to me not at this age of 50
for which something is too young but
much much earlier even earlier than my
childhood perhaps two weeks after I was
born so that I could have enjoyed the
princely feeling of being a child all my
life in fact now come to think of it
that is why I write and why I will
continue to write
you
[Music]